this video is going to be a bit
different to my usual videos but I want
to talk about material properties and
the words we use to describe them this
is information you're going to need to
fully understand future videos by the
end of this video I want you to
understand six key words that we use to
describe materials these are stiff
strong dr. brittle tough and hard with
these words you'll be able to describe
pretty much adding material and better
understand why certain materials are
used in different applications more
technical videos like this will be
uploaded to my second channel from now
on which you can subscribe to by
following this link I'll try and backup
the technical stuff with interesting
real-world examples first we are going
to learn what a tensile test is a
tensile test is a fundamental test in
material mechanics it's performed by
pulling a sample of material apart until
failure while measuring the force and
displacement it provides us with
something called a stress-strain curve
which tells us a lot about the materials
reactions to forces in this scenario the
stress is defined by the force applied
to the test sample divided by the
cross-sectional area this gives us units
of Newton's per meter squared which you
may recognize as the metric unit for
pressure Pascal's stress goes on the y
axis strain describes how much
deformation has occurred with that
applied force and it is found by
dividing the change in length by the
original length
this is placed on the x axis let's watch
this test again and see what information
we can get from the stress-strain graph
as the stress rises the material begins
to deform this initial linear region is
elastic deformation that means if we
remove the force the material will
regain its original shape think of how a
rubber band can deform hugely and still
come back to its original shape the end
of this linear elastic deformation is
marked by the yield point from here out
any additional stress will cause
permanent deformation this is called
plastic deformation the stress continues
to rise until it hits the ultimate
tensile strength point this is the
ultimate strength of the material the
most rassa can handle from here less
stress is needed as the material begins
to decrease in cross-section which can
see happening here this is called
necking this continues until the
material fractures we can get a lot of
really useful information from this
graph the first is young's modulus
otherwise known as the elastic modulus
this describes how stiff the material is
and it is obtained by finding the slope
of this linear
a steeper slope means a stiffer material
for example a high carbon steel may look
like this whereas a flexible material
with the low Young's modulus like Robert
would look like this this graph is not
to scale but it should give you an idea
of how this information is represented
Young's modulus is one of the most used
properties in engineering as we can use
it to predict deflection in a huge range
of scenarios yield strength and ultimate
tensile strength there are two other
important properties an engineer will
divide the yield or ultimate strength by
the safety factor to achieve the maxilla
will stress which is used to influence
the design of the product usually
engineers will aim to keep the max
possible stress well below failure but
safety factors differ between industries
so we've seen a stiff material on a
flexible material now let's look in a
material in between this material can be
described as tough for ductile tough
simply means the material can absorb a
lot of energy without breaking the area
under the graph here defines how much
energy is absorbed ductile means it
deforms under pressure the two previous
materials could also be considered
ductile
spring steel is a tough and ductile
material with a high yield strength
which is why it is used in Springs
Springs need to absorb energy without
permanently deforming the opposite of
ductile it's brittle a brittle material
as a material the breaks with very
little deformation glass ceramics and
cast iron all fall into this category
you can actually tell if a material is
brittle or ductile by examining the
fracture surface after they have broken
a dr. material will have this
characteristic cop and Cohen fracture
surface whereas brittle fractures have
granular flat looking fracture surfaces
some materials can go from doc tile to
brittle when their temperatures are
lowered this was actually a massive
problem during World War two with the
Liberty Ship several of these ships
literally broke in half with no warning
including the SS John P Gaines which
broke in half in the frigid waters of
the Bering Sea it was later discovered
that the grade of Steel been used became
brittle at lower temperatures this
problem was made worse by the stress
concentration at the hatches what you
learned about my first video while your
plain windows around this embrittlement
is also thought to have contributed to
the fracture of the Titanic's hull the
final material property I want to talk
about is hardness it is directly related
to the stiffness and yield strength of
the material but it is used to describe
how difficult it is to dent scratch in a
braid materials one way this material
property is measured is with the
rockwell hardness test this test
involves three steps first a minor load
is applied to the material line and
enter this establishes a zero point for
the second step a major load is then
added which indents the material and for
the final step the major load is removed
while maintaining the initial load the
difference in depth between the first
and third step is then used to calculate
the hardness of the material diamond is
a very hard material which is why it is
used in coding tools one of the
fantastic properties of steel is its
ability to be heat treated to have its
hardness tailored in different areas for
example with swords you want your
cutting edge to be hard but the core of
the blade to be ductile
this means the sword can bend under
pressure without breaking while the
cutting edge can resist damage as always
thanks for watching I wouldn't have the
opportunity to make videos like this
without sponsors like Liu merit Liu
merit is a new way to get college done
quickly from the University or college
you choose for a lot less money I was
lucky enough to get an education in
Ireland for pretty much free but there's
not a luxury many people have in the US
the cost of getting a higher degree from
a university is prohibitively expensive
and the lieu Merit Scholar Program is
out to change that
whether you're aspiring to go to college
or you're already there you merit can
allow you to complete up to 3 years of
college for $4,000 or less per year and
allow you to take classes from anywhere
in the world
so how does it work Allu merit counselor
will help you plan out your college path
getting credits from schools that are
guaranteed to transfer it to your target
school go to Liu Merit Scholar comm Ford
slash real engineering to see how much
you can save with Liu Merit Scholar they
will email you and give you a
personalized consultation to help you
save thousands on your education